alright I'm Morgan multi I'm from
hillsboro oregon and this is my bio farm
projects the Bulls behindest projects
essentially are to design and build a
bionic arm that functions very similar
to a natural human arm and the way I'm
doing that is i'm using a new type of
frame in that it's an endoskeleton
rather than an exoskeleton this is the
first bionic arm that I'm aware that
uses a endoskeleton and the skeleton
itself has all the same ranges of motion
that a natural human arm has so like if
you look at the pinky here I can curl
the pinky and I can rotate it out to the
side just like you all an act of human
pink you can
same thing with the center finger stuff
some of the joints got a little googling
together hole destroyed on the trip over
here so I can't show you everything but
I can turn the wrist on and it lifts up
a little bit and unfortunately these
solenoids that i'm using right now are
really inefficient in the future I'd
want to use finer wire solenoids because
they run in about 18 e to power and
generating the same mechanical force so
on the same matter power be able to
generate eight times a horse so I be
able to generate much strong much
stronger by nagaon